FEMALE SPEAKER: We're just
really excited to have Wajahat
here at Google.
And I'm going to let him kind
of speak a little bit about
himself and his journey
as a writer.
At the end, we'll open it up to
a discussion, so if anybody
has questions for him,
definitely stick around to
speak with him.
And we also have lunch
with him after.
If anybody hasn't eaten yet,
feel free to join us.
So Wajahat?
WAJAHAT ALI: All right.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
WAJAHAT ALI: Thank
you, Suhair.
Thank you, Suhair
for inviting me.
Thank you Google for filling up
this vast auditorium with
my admiring fans.
Being at Google marks the apex
of my professional career.
I've traveled far and wide to
finally be here, across the
great white 237 from a
mysterious land known as
Fremont, known as Fremontistan
to all the Muslims,
Pakistanis, and Afghans who live
there, home of the best
chutney kabab outside
of Kabul.
Thank you for inviting me to
your home, Google, known to
the world as the premier search
engine, known to your
enemies as the Death Star, and
known to all South Asian
parents as a fertile factory
for future spouses of their
unmarried children.
In fact, today's
Google speech--
and I'm being totally
serious--
has solidified my worth as a
human being for my family
members, who in their typical
South Asian bluntness see my
professional career
as a writer as--
I quote them--
"useless."
Today they said, try to
get a job at Google.
And I told them that--
I'm not making this up--
I said Google invited me
to speak for them.
And they're like, ha, ha but
after the speech, get a job.
Stop being useless.
True story.
Honored to be speaking here
today, but mostly--
and I won't lie.
This whole speech will
be very honest--
I'm mainly excited to be eating
at the famed Google
cafeteria, which
I-- thank you.
People are nodding their head.
They're like that is
why I work here.
I came from Pakistan just
for the cafeteria.
I hear it's a modern Shangri-la
of gluttonous
excess and unbridled
awesomeness.
And also--
I won't lie.
Just bear with me--
I have been told by every single
Pakistani working at
Google that I have to try the
infamous Google bathroom,
where like a robot
cleans your butt.
Right?
Or something?
Yeah, I heard it is a religious
experience, life
changing experience, and as
such I have loaded up
on fiber and water.
But continuing, I'm now going
to begin my speech with a
pathetic attempt to kiss up
to Google shamelessly by
celebrating the recent
remarkable failures of your
competition.
First, congratulation, Googlers
on the recent Apple
iPhone 5's dismal
map application.
Congratulations.
I used their map app to get to
Google today, and I ended up
at Yahoo instead.
Let's take a moment to
simultaneously mock and pity
the people who bought Facebook
at $32 a share.
I have just made that
my Facebook status.
So Googlers, Like it.
The irony will be priceless.
Let it be known, when and if I'm
ever invited to speak at
Facebook or Apple, I shall
mock Google Plus.
Sorry.
No offense to anyone.
I'm equal opportunity.
I also like to thank Security
who for some reason kept
calling me Rajeev.
I didn't correct them.
Thank you Rajeev, whoever you
are, for your parking spot.
Once I entered Google, I saw
so many South Asians, I
thought I was at Cisco.
And a part of my heart swells
with pride, and I looked at
these random South Asians,
I did the Miyagi look.
For those of you who have seen
Miyagi, I'm talking about Pat
Morita from the original
"Karate Kid," not
Will Smith's son.
At the end of "Karate Kid," Pat
Morita, Miyagi, looks at
Daniel-san with a
sense of pride.
He looks at him like this.
And I looked at these random
South Asians with pride in my
face, and they just kept
staring back at me, not
eliciting the response
I wanted.
And I think a few of them are
like who's this weird tech
support from India?
I do not hail from India.
The family hails from the
motherland known as Pakistan,
which is the most popular
country on Earth right now.
When people think of Pakistan,
they think of rainbows and
cupcakes and ponies
and babies.
Pakistan is the most toxic brand
name in the universe.
This is a true story.
A few of my friends
have heard this.
A Palestinian man came
up to me last year
and said the following.
Bro-- bro--
things are really bad in
Pakistan right now bro.
When a Palestinian takes pity
on you, you're effed.
All right?
You're effed.
And to make matters worse,
I have the hat trick of
kryptonite toxic brand names.
I'm an American Muslim of
Pakistani descent or a
Muslim-American Pakistani.
Awesome.
Being Pakistani-American is so
bad right now that I'm forced
to tell people I'm pre-partition
Indian.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
WAJAHAT ALI: This
is a good crowd.
This is a good crowd.
Yeah, Muslim-Pakistani American
as a brand name is
about as popular as death,
taxes, and herpes.
No offense to herpes.
But speaking about stories, in
all honesty, the title of
today's story is, I think,
From Chaiwallah to--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Playwright.
WAJAHAT ALI: To Playwright.
The Rise of a Pakistani-American
writer.
True story.
I was in Nepal, Suhair was
after me for a title.
I was exhausted.
I wrote the title, thinking it
was a joke, that no one would
ever seriously consider
that as a title.
Suhair, two days later, sends
me the official Google
letterhead that says "From
Chaiwallah to Playwright."
FEMALE SPEAKER: I liked it.
WAJAHAT ALI: The Rise of--
I was hoping-- a Pre-partition
Indian Writer.
But no, I am indeed a
Pakistani-American writer.
And speaking about stories, I'll
tell you a quick story
about how I got to
Google today.
But before I talk about stories,
there's this great
quotation by a poet Muriel
Rukeyser, which says the
following: the universe is made
up of stories, not atoms.
The universe is made of
stories, not atoms.
Here's another great quote.
Human beings are natural
storytellers.
They can't help telling
stories.
They turn things that aren't
really into stories, into
stories because they like
narratives so much.
Everything, faith, science, love
needs a story for people
to find it plausible.
No story, no sale.
That's writer Adam Gopnik in
"The New Yorker" talking about
Jonathan Gottschall's book "The
Storytelling Animal,"
which posits that the human
being is the unique
storytelling animal in
all of existence.
That's how we operate.
That's how we communicate.
That's how we learn.
Even in ancient seventh-century
Arabia, the
storyteller was valued more
than the swordsman.
I know you guys won't
believe me.
It's a true story.
Now this was a culture where
tribes needed the most skilled
swordsman because raids were
part of daily activity.
And they needed protection.
Yet in those days, when a famed
talented poet came to
their land, they insisted
he would stay and
perform for the community.
And again, this makes sense
considering that the human
being is a unique storytelling
animal.
Stories give humans identity
and purpose.
Think about religion.
Regardless if you like religion
or not, it's a
powerful force.
Christians--
how do they learn about
how to behave?
Their morals, their etiquette?
The stories of Jesus.
In fact, Jesus taught through
parables which are stories.
For Muslims, very popular right
now, for those of you
who don't know, they follow
the Hadith, which is a
collection of stories that talk
about the etiquette of
the prophet Muhammad.
Stories give humans identity
and purpose.
They also help us pass down our
values, ideals, beliefs,
and cultures.
For example, wherever I've
gone in the world, every
single culture knows the story
of the boy who cried wolf.
Every culture, every language.
Every culture knows that that's
a story you tell your
children to teach
them not to lie.
Now we could sit there and be
didactic and say hey, don't
lie or I'll hurt you.
But instead we couch that moral
in a narrative, in a
story, in a story featuring a
whining annoying boy and a
hungry murderous wolf,
which is slightly
disturbing, but it works.
Stories are also how we
brand and present
ourselves to the world.
Every major company has an About
Us section, which talks
about their origin.
Stories are how we
meet people.
Stories help us communicate.
Stories are how we learn
about one another.
In America, in fact, when you
meet someone for the first
time, you often ask them hey
man, what's your story?
Followed by you're paying
for the bill.
Successful stories, the ones
that stick and resonate, need
people's emotional investment.
So let me tell you of a quick
story today in a half hour
about a dude named
Wajahat Ali--
that's me--
born in El Camino hospital,
raised in Fremontistan,
California, graduate of
Bellarmine an all-boys Jesuit
Catholic high school, who got
an English degree from UC
Berkeley, despite not knowing
any English when he was born,
for the first four years of his
life, ended up writing a
play in college for a English
class assignment, who then
went to law school at UC Davis,
got licensed as an
attorney, couldn't find work,
applied to Google,
didn't get the job.
Somehow I ended up
with an unlikely
irreverent odd career--
or hobby, according to my
South Asian family--
as a professional paid writer
or professional lafunga,
according to my family.
Lafunga for those of you who
speak Urdu means loafer.
And now he is at Google
speaking.
So are you guys still with me?
That was awesome, enthusiastic,
wonderful.
You just really, just inspired
me to continue.
All right.
Here we go.
Once upon a time, there was a
shy, awkward, constantly sick,
only child of Pakistan immigrant
parents, born in Bay
Area, California, who was the
only left-handed member of his
entire family, which made every
single family member in
Karachi, Pakistan think
he was a djinn--
true story--
who walked around in a white
shirt smeared with lentil
stains and sweat patches, who
was addicted to chai, because
his grandfather used to feed
him his chai with teaspoons
when he was a kid.
And when the kid, who grew up,
he had his own little small
chai cup with his own chai.
And every day, this
kid was healthy.
And healthy is a Pakistani
term for big boned.
And healthy and big boned are
always accompanied by this
motion, which is very,
very subtle.
He was so healthy that his
grandmother and mother used to
be able to find pants for him
only in the young adult
section of Mervyn's when the
kid was six years old.
And-- true story-- they bought
these pants, and because the
kid was so healthy, they had to
roll up the pants sleeves.
And when the kid asked how come
his pants were different
from everyone else, the mom
said it's fashion sense.
It's a good fashion sense.
He was so healthy that he went
to Harker School in Saratoga
where there were uniforms--
humiliating.
He was forced to wear
Husky pants.
And these Husky pants--
true story--
have a big patch on the right
side of your butt with big
bold letters saying Husky.
Very subtle.
When entering preschool, the
appropriately titled Child's
Hideaway, the kid only spoke
three words of English.
The three words were
the following.
"Shut up" because his mother
used to tell him shut up,
"idiot" because his
mother used to say
often shut up, idiot.
And for those of you who were a
child of the '80s, you guys
remember that commercial
uh oh spaghetti-o?
Anyone?
One or two people,
three people.
I'm old and decrepit.
Awesome.
Uh oh spaghetti-o.
And the kid couldn't speak
English, so he said uh oh
pas-getti-o.
Three words of English.
A year later while attending
James Leach Elementary School,
the teachers didn't know what
to do with this kid or any
other minority, as
a matter of fact.
So they put him and the four
other minorities in ESL, which
is English as Second Language.
It was him, two Asian-American
girls, the black kid who was
there because he was the only
black kid in school, spoke
perfect English, and this kid.
True story.
And for several months, a
teacher used to stand in front
of this kid and used
to say whatever.
And the Pakistani kid looked
back and said "whatewer".
And the teacher said
no, no, whatever.
And the kid looked back
and said whatewer.
This happened for months.
And until finally the kid
figured out that Vs and Ws are
not the same.
The kid also made many, many
fateful trips to the
motherland, Karachi, Pakistan,
which left many deep
impressions literally.
For example, the first time
he went, he got hit by a
motorcycle.
Awesome.
Four years old.
Kid goes straight
up in the air,
lands flat on his forehead.
Forehead explodes.
Doctors say if he would have
landed one inch to the left or
one inch to the right, he
would have been pffbt--
flatlined.
The local doctors apparently
didn't have sophisticated
equipment, and they operated on
him with a dull knife and
spoon, which gave him a scar to
this day that makes it look
like a Klingon baby.
In the '90s, he proudly showed
off what he called the Klingon
scar to women thinking it would
work in getting dates.
It didn't.
In the 21st century, he evolved
his pop culture nuance
and said this is the Harry
Potter scar, thinking it would
get him women.
It didn't.
Apparently at age nine, because
he didn't have enough
of Pakistan, he went back,
where he got pneumonia--
awesome--
which went undiagnosed
for 2 1/2 weeks.
And so he lost 40 pounds and lay
dying essentially on the
straw mat on the second floor
of his grandmother's
building-- true story.
And the grandmother's tenant,
a Pakistani whiskey-drinking
American-educated doctor, who
talked like this in an
interesting accent--
that's how he talked--
came upstairs to do a routine
check-up and said (PAKISTANI
ACCENT) oh my god, this
boy has pneumonia.
Take him to the hospital.
Which they did.
And they said (PAKISTANI ACCENT)
Oh, he has pneumonia.
Oh, good you brought him.
That's good.
And, true story, it
was very casual.
And they're like (PAKISTANI
ACCENT) yeah, if it wasn't one
more week, he would have
not-- bicharo would
have not made it.
And so I survived.
And again in high school, the
kid said you know what?
Let's go back to the motherland,
where in high
school, he went back and
contracted malaria and a 104
high temperature
for three days.
Whatever doesn't kill you gives
you mosquito larva in
your bloodstream.
Rewind, fifth grade, again at
Harker School in Saratoga, the
overweight, sweaty, socially
awkward, Pakistani,
left-handed, healthy boy with
lentil stains on his shirt
also suffered from
severe allergies.
He was so sick that he had
missed 37 days of school.
They were about to
kick him out.
He had to make a plea to the
principal to let him stay.
OK, the school was just about to
kick him out and finally a
competent doctor named
Dr. Biederman--
who did not work at Kaiser.
No offense to Kaiser--
give him medication that
actually worked.
And so this kid recovered, but
had to work harder in fifth
grade than he did in all
of high school to
make an epic comeback.
Tutors, after schools learning,
catching up a
month's worth of work.
Things were looking bleak, until
one day, his fifth grade
teacher, Ms. Peterson, hailing
from Kentucky, asked the class
to write a one page fictional
short story.
Now this was 1991, a strange
time in America, where Madonna
had conical breasts, Z.
Cavariccis were all the rage.
Anyone know Z. Cavariccis?
You had them?
Thank you for being bold
enough to admit it.
We all owned a pair.
Will Smith was known as
the Fresh Prince.
And Kevin Costner was chosen
to play Robin Hood.
You guys remember this?
So because of this, the kid
decided to write a parody and
satire of Robin Hood.
And the kid's story went
from one page to
five pages to 10 pages.
The teacher loved the kid's
story and made him perform it
in front of the fifth grade.
For the first time ever, this
sweaty, healthy, [URDU]
healthy kid, awkward, shy,
performed the story.
The classroom loved it.
Then they said perform
it in front of the
fifth and sixth grade.
They loved it.
The kid brought home the
story to his father.
The father reads the story and
says (PAKISTANI ACCENT) Beta--
which means son--
you might have a talent.
You should consider
becoming a writer.
The mother, who was in the
kitchen, overheard this, with
fear in her eyes, ran out and
said (PAKISTANI ACCENT) yes,
but first become a doctor.
This was 1991.
The age was 10.
Let's do a group exercise.
In South Asian families, there's
a holy trinity of
professions.
Let's go with number one.
What's number one?
AUDIENCE: Doctor.
WAJAHAT ALI: Doctor.
Number two?
AUDIENCE: Engineer.
WAJAHAT ALI: Engineer.
Number three?
AUDIENCE: Lawyer.
WAJAHAT ALI: Not lawyer.
No one cares about
lawyers, yet.
Number three is a dubious
businessman who somehow makes
a lot of money and buys a
suburban home, marries a wife
who's around seven
on the hotness
scale, and has a Lexus.
Number four?
Failure.
All right?
Those are your four options
as occupations.
But because of this momentous
occasion where this kid told
this story, for the first time
in his life, this overweight,
shy, awkward, healthy, lentil
stained boy, who was healthy,
gained confidence and a sense
of empowerment, and for the
briefest of moments, for about
two hours after the story,
even some popularity.
And ever since that day, the
awkward boy ended up spending
all of his free time investing
in the passion of
storytelling, performance,
movies, and reading.
During the summer, him and his
best friend [? Kashif ?]
made their own home movies,
because no one invited them to
parties because they
were dorks.
And they wrote, directed, acted,
and edited in their own
homemade movies, such as the
ambitious and epic "Formula"
trilogy, featuring a diabolical
scientist who
creates a formula that
could destroy Earth.
But each time his nefarious plot
is thwarted by the gruff,
surly detective--
played by me--
who breaks protocol and a few
necks but saves the day.
They also do their own takes
on popular movies.
If you guys remember, in the
1991, there was a celluloid
classic by the name of "Tango
and Cash," starring Kurt
Russell and Sly Stallone.
We did our own called "Lambada
and Doe." Think about it.
The boy grew up, stayed healthy
and end up going to an
all-boys Jesuit-taught high
school, Bellarmine, where he
emerged as the token
representative of all things
Pakistan, South Asia,
Muslim, and Islam.
He must have given eight
talks on Islam
throughout his entire career.
He had a choice--
to stay isolated in the corner
as the token, not sharing his
religious or cultural identity,
or be authentic, be
himself, be open, and
communicate his
multi-hyphenate identity to his
Catholic diverse peers.
So he embraced his role as the
cultural ambassador of his
peoples and enjoyed
relating tales and
communicating stories.
In his senior year, he decides
he's going to try his hand at
improv comedy.
And he successfully joined the
school comedy troupe entitled
The Sanguine Humours, where he
created the endearing popular
comedy icon known as Captain
Brown Man, an ornery, one-eyed
pirate captain with a hook for a
hand, who always entered the
stage saying daar, the name
is Captain Brown Man.
It worked.
At that time, it
was a huge hit.
We weren't that politically
correct in those days.
Once upon a time, continuing,
there was a young healthy,
overweight boy who grew up,
entered UC Berkeley and
decided to go to the gym for
the first time in his life.
And he slimmed down.
And he decided that lentil
stains would always be on his
white shirts.
So he started wearing
black and gray.
And then he dressed a bit
better, was socially active,
joined a lot of student groups
such as the Muslim Student
Association, which apparently
makes him a member of Ikhwan
and Hamas and Hezbollah for
the rest of his life.
I'm just kidding.
This is taped, right?
Barack Obama is not a
Muslim president.
If he is Muslim, he is the
worst Muslim of all time.
The dude eats pork openly.
All right? (PAKISTANI ACCENT)
I love America.
So I was a member of the Muslim
Student Association,
joined the Student Advocate
Office, and ended up taking
way too many academic units
because I had no idea what I
wanted to be when I grew up.
And every day, this kid--
me--
ended up running around like a
crazy, headless chicken, not
sleeping too much, and having
crazy fun times.
Along with a few friends at UC
Berkeley, we created the first
sketch comedy troupe entitled
The [? Gawad ?]
Squad, where they wrote,
directed, and
edited their own sketches.
Over the next three years,
I ended up playing a gay
vampire, a Scottish
immigrant-owner of an Olive
Garden, a Pakistani student
living with belligerent
Italian immigrants, a
well-endowed Italian-American
liquor store owner--
don't ask--
and a Ukrainian weight
lifter, among many
other enduring titles.
This boy spent his nights,
tee-totaling, a Muslim dork
who didn't drink, who never
partied, spending an
inordinate amount of time in is
awesome apartment playing
host and playing video games,
such as NBA 2K and NFL 2K,
entertaining similarly dorky,
horny, virginal,
Muslim-American bachelors,
engaging in practical jokes,
sophomoric humor, and pretty
much being dorks, 24/7.
And as the perpetual host of
these dorks, he ended up
making vats of chai every
day for four years.
By the end of his junior year,
his chai had become infamous
across the nation, legendary
because it nourished the
bellies of horny, single,
dorky, Muslim men.
And even when I was lucky,
a few women came into the
apartment, only for
five minutes.
His senior year of college, he
was chosen to be a board
member of the student group,
Muslim Student Association,
which of course brands him a
lifetime member of Hezbollah,
Hamas, Ikhwan, and
everything else.
I'm just kidding.
Because this is on YouTube.
He reluctantly accepted.
The year was 2001.
Also on a whim, that same year,
he decided to apply to a
short story writing class.
He had three choices.
Each class was taught by
a different professor.
One class was taught by this
guy named Ishmael Reed.
The guy--
this is me now--
I had no idea who Ishmael
Reed was.
I simply liked the
name Ishmael.
It was very biblical.
And I'm like you know what, I'm
leaning towards applying
to Ishmael's class.
I asked a faculty advisor out of
all these three, who should
I apply to, because I can
only apply to one?
He said well, this guy, Ishmael,
he kind of lets you
do your own thing.
He gives you freedom.
Done.
Sold.
The dude's name was Ishmael.
He gives you freedom.
I applied to Ishmael Reed's
class on a whim.
3:58 PM.
Wheeler Hall, third floor.
Deadline was 4:00 PM.
I wrote it in pen.
I didn't have lines, so the
paper went like this.
It was curving this
way with my ink.
It looked like a Lahori
publication of a book.
For those of you who know about
Lahori publication, you
know they don't print their
stuff in a straight line.
And all I had was a 12-page play
script, because you had
to submit a 15-page
short story.
I didn't have a short story.
So I submitted one
of my [? Gawad ?]
Squad scripts about two horny,
thieving English noblemen and
a magical donkey that
wore a monocle.
Yeah, I know.
It was genius.
The play was entitled
"All This for an
Ass." It's all I had.
I submitted it.
All was well, because I
got into the class.
It's 2001.
Senior year I was 20, about to
turn 21, until one day, the
two towers fell.
And there was madness.
And all of us 20-year-olds,
who were just kids, just
students, part of the Muslim
Student Association, all of a
sudden became the accidental
activists, the cultural
ambassadors of 1,400 years of
Islamic civilization, where we
were forced to know everything
about Iraq and Afghanistan and
the Koran and Prophet Muhammad
and Muslims and South Asians,
and hell, even Sikhs,
and everything.
And we were just students,
but we got hate
mail coming from people.
We had to represent a community
that was terrified
and afraid.
Muslim women who wore the
hijab, which is the head
covering, at UC Berkeley were
afraid of going out to school.
It was a crazy time,
crazy climate for
those of you who remember.
And for whatever reason,
someone, my roommate who made
the website, for the MSA,
decided it would be fun to
name me the social coordinator
and public relations liaison.
So guess who was getting all the
press contacts and all the
interviews?
Me.
I ended up becoming what I call
the accidental activist
for about 75% of
my senior year.
For three weeks after 9/11, I
couldn't even go to school.
Now, fast forward three weeks,
I'm in Ishmael Reid's class.
I'm up to perform
a short story.
Crap.
I got to write a short
story, take it to
class, and perform it.
At 4:00 AM, I came up with a
story about two ogres who were
married for 50 years celebrating
their 50th wedding
anniversary who secretly hated
one another, poisoned each
other's goblets and are waiting
the entire time to
kill one another.
I know, genius.
This was before "Shrek,"
so I was a genius.
I was just late on
that ogre cake.
Six hours later, 10:00 AM, go
to class, read the story,
which was entitled "Bulbous
and Rotunda's 50th Wedding
Anniversary." Class loves it.
I'm terrified, because I think
Ishmael Reed's going to chew
me out for missing class
for three weeks.
Ishmael says see
me after class.
I'm scared out of my mind.
Ishmael says you're a
natural playwright.
You don't know it.
Don't waste your time in my
short story writing class.
I'm going to take you outside
of my short story writing
class, and you're going to
have to write me a play.
Write me a play.
Write me 20 pages.
You pass the class.
I'm like dude, you're crazy.
I don't know how to
write a play.
Just let me write
short stories.
He goes nope.
Write me a play.
You know what?
As an African-American, we have
been through this before.
I can see 10 years down the
line, it's going to be a tough
time for Muslims
and Pakistanis.
Your stories aren't
being told.
What people do see is an
extremist narrative.
Sometimes, not only the way to
fight back, but the way to
push forward is through
arts and culture.
You should write me a story
about a family.
You know what?
Make it a Pakistani family.
Aren't you a Muslim?
Make it a Muslim-American
Pakistani family.
You ever read "Death of a
Salesman?" I'm like yes.
You ever read "Long
Day's Journey into
Night?" I said yes.
Something like that.
All right, bye.
So I'm like crap.
I get to write 20
pages of a play.
I've never written a
play in my life.
What am I going to do?
Now, for those of you who don't
know, Moslems celebrate
something called Ramadan.
And up to a certain age, when
you're young, at the end of
Ramadan, you get something
called eidi,
which is like money.
So I was like 20, and that was
the last year I got eidi.
I got like $20.
I was broke, and I was poor.
I took the $20 to this cultural
relic of the 20th
century known as Borders.
You guys might remember it.
I went to the Drama section.
I said Plays, picked
up two plays.
They came within $20.
Being the son of Pakistan
immigrants, thank you, I
looked at the refund policy.
And they said within 15 days,
if you return the plays in
good condition, you get
your money back.
I'm like done.
Read the plays within 15 days,
went back every 15 days, got
two more plays.
Did this for two months, tried
to figure how to--
true story.
Hey, it was their policy.
I just exploited it.
Son of Pakistani immigrants.
We stretch $1 to make it $20.
I'm proud.
I don't care.
Figure out how to write a play,
started the play for my
21st birthday in
November 2001.
And finished it for my
23rd birthday, 2003.
The way that happened is
submitted 20 pages and Ishmael
liked it so much, every couple
months he said give me five
more pages, give me
five more pages.
Finished it as a birthday
present to myself
at the age of 23.
And because of that, Ishmael
Reed in 2003 invited me to
Spencer's Grotto in Berkeley and
said the script is great.
And now we do a staged
reading.
I, of course, asked what's
a staged reading?
He said my wife here, Carla
Blank, she's a theater scholar
and dramaturge.
She'll direct the
staged reading.
Carla looked over at him
and said really?
I will?
He goes yeah, yeah, yeah,
you'll do it.
True story.
So I went to Sheik Google--
true story-- and typed in staged
reading to figure out
what it was.
Staged reading is essentially
when you get a couple actors,
you put them on a couple of
chairs, and they act out the
play while reading the script.
That's a staged reading.
If you're successful,
you get 50 people.
Now mind you, at this time, I
was 23 years old, jobless, had
to move back home, where I was
in my high school bedroom, and
I woke up every day to
find $5 in my wallet.
And when I asked who put the
$5 in my wallet, my father
said to me he used to sneak
the $5 in my wallet every
night, because he said
(PAKISTANI ACCENT) no man
should be without $5.
And so out of both pity and
kindness, I moved back to my
family home, with nothing
much going on for
me except this play.
Now what happened was I believed
in the power of
storytelling.
This is now 2003.
Interesting time.
And I wanted to inspire and
empower my South Asian and
Muslim communities and make
them believe that there's
power in their stories.
And I wanted to make
them realize that
their stories had value.
So what we did is I said I'm
going to reach out to my
community first and foremost.
So what we did was, we used the
internets to make a call
to anyone who was remotely brown
with a pulse who wanted
to audition for this play that
I'd written called "The
Domestic Crusaders" about a
family of Muslim-Pakistani
Americans, six characters, a
grandfather, the Pakistani
immigrants, and their three
American-born children, who
all convene on the family
house for one day.
Six roles.
I said anyone remotely with a
tan, with a pulse, interested
in performing.
That's the only prerequisite.
Come try out for this play.
Now we did auditions
at Chandni.
Every community has a Chandni.
Chandni Restaurant slash
community hall is where people
go to get married, get divorced,
have buffets, have
religious experiences, convert
to Islam, convert out of
Islam, do ameens, do bismillahs,
do the Hanukkahs,
do Sikh weddings.
Every community has a Chandni.
I told the Chandni owner
I'm going to do
additions at your place.
It's a local place.
Can you just give me a space?
He said I'll let you come
on the weekends.
You have to buy at least
seven buffets.
I'm like done.
I'll promise that the people
who come audition, I'll
convince them to buy buffets,
which happened.
The first week, the first time
we did it, eight people, 8 to
13 people did it.
They came in, did the
staged reading.
They were very hesitant,
skeptical.
But they read the script and
within an hour I could tell
they were jazzed.
The second week, word of mouth
spread, 20 people.
did the audition.
At the end of a month and a
half, 135 people auditioned
for the play.
Now we need a place
to stage the play.
So we went to Chandni's
competition, Mehran
Restaurant, which is right
next door to Chandni, not
making this up, in Newark,
California.
And I said to Fayaz, the owner,
I said what will it
cost for me to use your hall,
transform it into a dinner
theater experience, and
you could give me
a South Asian buffet?
He said $15 cost.
I realized I couldn't
handle it.
So I brought in a heavy hitter,
my father, as my
messenger, who came in, rolled
up his sleeves, had a sit-down
with Fayaz, and said
the following.
(PAKISTANI ACCENT) Fayaz.
Why do you disrespect
me this way?
True story.
We've known each other
for a long time.
I've given you good business.
$15?
I will make you good business.
And we will transform Mehran
into not just a community
hall, but into a dinner
theatre experience.
And Fayaz thought about it, and
he brought the cost down
to $6 for a five course buffet
meal, endless supply of chai,
and kir dessert with the hall.
OK.
I went to another relative, an
uncle, and said if I gave you
a dinner theatre experience,
stage reading, and
a buffet for $15.
Would you come?
True story.
Uncle looks at me and says
(PAKISTANI ACCENT) if you make
it $10, I'll think about it.
So we made it $10.
We made it $10.
And they said if 50 people
showed up, it'd be a success.
We publicized using this
antiquated technology from the
20th century called Evite--
you might remember it.
It still exists--
used listservs, reached out to
local South Asian communities,
organizations, members,
word of mouth spread.
Guess how many people
showed up?
Interactive crowd.
Love it.
450.
450 people showed up.
The capacity was 220.
We fit 350.
Don't ask me how.
And most people who showed up,
to be honest, they showed up
out of curiosity.
And they said--
I want to speak Urdu,
but I know this is
going to be on YouTube.
But a lot of Pakistani uncles
were like (PAKISTANI ACCENT)
this is-- what is
this, this play?
We'll come out and see it.
Let's see it.
And one Pakistani uncle came
up to me and said--
true story--
he said beta-- son--
why don't you do something
useful with
your life, like protest.
Look what's happening in 2003,
all that's happening.
Go protest.
What is this playwriting,
shaywriting?
True story--
I'll get back to that
uncle in a second.
So we had no money and we
rehearsed for this play in the
backyard of Ishmael Reed--
my producer--
and Carla Blank, his
wife, the director.
And just a quick note
on Ishmael Reed.
I was so--
I was such a bumpkin that in
college, I didn't know that
Ishmael Reed was a MacArthur
genius winner, twice-nominated
Pulitzer writer.
And in his backyard means
six other Pakistanis are
rehearsing where my mom made the
dhal and biriyani on the
weekends and I, of course,
supplied the chai.
We did the play.
The play was a huge success.
We're like awesome,
great, wonderful.
I think I'm done with my life.
I decide to go to law school
to become "honorable."
And during the first year of law
school, during the summer,
where we're supposed to actually
do something useful
like apply to a corporation,
an opportunity presented
itself to perform the play
at the Berkeley Repertory
Theater, which is a major
regional theater.
We decided we'll do it.
I was completely broke,
had no money.
I got a little bit of money
from my friends.
Again, we performed.
We did the rehearsals in the
backyard of Ishmael Reed and
Carla Blank.
We needed to dress the set
to make it look like a
Pakistani-American home.
So naturally, we used furniture
from my home.
My grandmother comes home one
day, comes downstairs, and
says beta, are we moving?
And my grandmother is
a 75-year-old heart
patient at that time.
We had to sit her down and say
no, no, It'll come back in
three days, we promise.
Now the play was always
intended for a global
multi-cultural audience.
People, again, made fun of us,
said no one would show up.
We had no money, so we had to
stretch the dollar into $20,
use new media.
Needed to create a press
release, so went to Sheik
Google, type in press release.
How to make press release.
Figured it out, wrote a press
release, sent it out.
Got local press, got the front
page of SF Chronicle which
then intrigued a BBC journalist
to come by to the
2005 Berkeley Repertory Theatre
performance, which was
a week after the 7-7 London
subway bombing, of course,
perpetrated by Pakistani
Muslims.
And everyone at that time, 2005,
finally Pakistani came
in the news, unfortunately
for wrong reasons.
And everyone was curious
about this city
in India named Pakistan.
And you're like no, dude,
Pakistan's a country-- just
don't worry about it.
Pakistan's a different
country.
But everyone was curious.
Play sold out.
Got standing ovations,
multi-cultural audience.
A couple months later we did it
at San Jose for 9/11/2005.
Play sold out again.
BBC--
that same journalist-- sent back
word to BBC headquarters.
They did a 10-minute piece on
us, all right on 9/11/2005.
The BBC folks liked the play so
much that they said can we,
on our BBC letterhead, solicit
every theater in London to
perform this play,
because it's so
important and we need it.
I thought about it
and said yes.
Yes, you can.
But at that time, 2005--
2005, for those of you who
remember, if we can go into
our 1985 DeLorean and do time
travel back to 2005, it was a
crazy time where Dixie Chicks
were considered traitors.
You guys remember this?
Dixie chicks are the whitest
women on Earth.
They're blond.
They sing country music.
They love the God, and
they're married.
Could you imagine what
they would have done
with a guy like me?
2005?
So a lot of Pakistanis and
Muslims-- and the play's not
controversial-- were like do you
really want this message
out there right now?
And the feedback we got from lot
of theaters was they liked
the play, but they wanted
me to change it.
So I said how do you want
me to change it?
Oh they're like, you know,
just some other
things, just change it.
I'm like can you tell me what
you want me to change?
And they're like, just
you know-- ehh
[WISHY WASHY SOUNDS]
And so we realize that was code
word for take away some
of the politics, take away
some of the religion.
So we decided we had to wait.
Fast forward.
Now I would think that
I have these
two successful premieres.
Life would be awesome.
I'd become a wealthy
playwright.
I'd travel the world.
And I'd sleep on the bed of
money with dozens of women,
and my life would be made.
Wrong.
Fast forward, 2007.
I graduated from law school.
And I end up back in my family
home in my high school
bedroom, completely broke with
my father putting $5 bills in
my wallet every day.
Out of desperation and
frustration, I decide to write
an article.
And this article was a truncated
article from a
report from actually a paper
I'd written in law school
about Blackwater and private
military firms in Iraq.
I submit it to an
online magazine.
It got published.
They said if you want to submit
any time, submit it.
I said really?
They said really.
I was hooked.
I started submitting op-eds.
I wanted to interview this dude
named Seymour Hirsch,
who's this Pulitzer-winning
journalist, just
for the hell of it.
Because if you're jobless
sitting at home going crazy,
and you get ideas like I want
to interview Seymour Hirsch.
So I went to Sheik Google,
Google Seymour
Hirsch phone number.
And I found one.
I swear.
Sorry Seymour Hirsch.
And I cold call Seymour
Hirsch.
Guy picks up the phone.
I'm like I'm a freelance
journalist, Seymour Hirsch.
I would like to interview you.
He says call me back
two weeks later.
We'll schedule the interview.
I call him back two
weeks later.
He was a bad mood.
I'm like I'm that
Muslim-American journalist who
wants to interview you.
He goes huh?
I already did the Muslims.
I did Al Jazeera.
And I'm like no, no, this
is something else.
So he said well, if you want
to-- after 20 minutes--
being the son of Pakistani
immigrants, I kept him on the
phone, convinced him
to talk to me.
He said well, if you want to--
if we do this hypothetical
interview, throw me a
hypothetical question.
I threw him a hypothetical
question.
He answered it.
I said if we did a hypothetical
interview, that's
how it'd go.
He goes hypothetical
interview?
This is the effing interview.
Get out your recorder.
Let's go, let's go.
I didn't have a recorder, so I
sat there with my phone on my
shoulder and typed transcript
of the entire interview.
That was my first interview.
It got published, led to another
online magazine saying
if you want to publish
anytime, go ahead.
I said sure.
Within six months, I published
50 articles--
maybe 75 within a period
of a year.
And all a sudden, people were
calling me a journalist.
I said OK.
People are inviting me to
journalism conferences to give
talks to journalists, which I
thought was kind of hilarious.
But I went because it
was free, and they
gave me free food.
Now fast forward,
spring of 2007.
I get a job in a kind of shady
immigration law firm run by
South Asians.
And I get a lot of free time.
So I'm working as an
attorney finally.
And there's a guy named Barack
Hussein Obama who could have
become President.
And I thought to myself the
tides are changing.
Maybe is now the time for this
play "Domestic Crusaders."
So also, I was about
to turn 28.
And anyone who's younger than
the age of 30, you'd realize
that some of us go through a
premature midlife crisis.
And I thought I would die
by the age of 30.
I literally thought
I would die.
I thought I would wake up at the
age of 30, have a cardiac,
like heart attack die--
like the Earth would open
up, swallow my body.
It'd be over.
So I'm like I need to do
something before I die
at the age of 30.
The only thing I've done which
is worthwhile is this play
"Domestic Crusaders." I
have to get this play
staged in New York.
For whatever reason, I said that
we have to do it on 9/11.
And then I said I have
to get it published.
This is what I must do before
I die at the age of 30.
Now what happened is I found
someone called the Nuyorican
Poets Cafe in New York that
said if you raise $24,000
within one year, we'll give you
five weeks in our theater.
We'll give you from 9/11/09
to October.
They said you have to raise
$24,000, and we'll
give you the space.
So what I did was I created an
elevator pitch in the form of
a half a page email.
I used Sheik Google.
I used the internets.
I used your competition
Macebook.
I used the Twitter-- is Twitter
your competition?
Not yet, right?
Not yet.
I used Twitter.
I use the blogosphere I used any
network I could and sent
this elevator pitch in the form
of an email out, like a
message in a bottle to
do fund raising.
I also opened up a
Paypal account.
The first fundraiser was done
by my Vietnamese-American
friends from high school
who raised me $1,500.
A lady by the name
of [? Zebag ?]
[? Ball ?] all the way in New
York read my stories, said I
believe in what you're
trying to do.
Let me invite you to New York.
Maybe we can raise some money.
Went to New York for the first
time in my life, raise the
second $1,500.
Word of mouth started
to spread.
And little by little, $5 here,
$10 here, $15 there, I ended
up raising $31,000.
The last money came two weeks
before the play's premiere due
to an anonymous check.
Thank you.
But what really happened was I
realized we needed messengers,
because no one wanted to hear
the story of a Pakistani
chaiwallah, doing a play with
six Pakistani characters who
aren't doing bhangra or
blowing themselves up.
And I realized in the world
we live in, we need to get
validated by the people.
Now who are the people?
I'll finish up in two minutes.
Who are the people?
Good question.
After every "Domestic Crusader"
performance, someone
from my ethnic community--
"ethnic"--
used to come up to me and
say the following.
(WHISPERED) Psst.
Wajahat.
Come here.
I'm like what?
[INAUDIBLE] come here.
I'm like what's up?
(PAKISTANI ACCENT)
Play was great.
But what do the people
think about it?
I'm like well you saw the
play in front of people.
And there were people to your
left, people to your right.
The people seem to like it.
They gave a standing ovation.
Like (PAKISTANI ACCENT) Bsht,
not those people.
The People.
And here is just some community
interaction.
The people is a code
word for who?
AUDIENCE: Intelligence.
WAJAHAT ALI: Not intelligence.
Nice job of being politically
correct.
AUDIENCE: White people.
WAJAHAT ALI: White people.
Yes, the white people.
I said don't worry about
the white people.
The white people are OK.
You don't have to hold the
white people's hands.
I have faith in the
white people.
I love the white people.
Some of my best friends
are the people.
Don't worry about it.
It'll be OK.
But we realized we need
messengers and validators.
So I made a list of 250
people I respected.
I really respected.
Writers, poets, playwrights,
activists, and I didn't have
any of their email
or contacts.
So for a year, until 3:00 AM at
night, using Sheik Google--
I'm not making this up-- and
search engines, I found any
email contact I could--
a publicist, a manager,
an agent, anything.
Created an Excel sheet, send
out my half-page elevator
pitch, half-page
elevator pitch.
I got the contact of Emma
Thompson, Academy Award
winning actress.
Through her publicist, she sends
me an email back finally
saying your play sounds great.
I want to read it.
Send me a hard copy.
I send a hard copy.
I think, you know what,
I'm never going to
hear back from her.
A couple months later, a friend
of mine, Gundar Strads,
who gets all the "Domestic
Crusader" mail, says, hey,
there's a letter from some
lady named Emma.
Emma Tumps.
You know anyone named
Emma Tumps?
I'm like I don't know anyone
named Emma Tumps.
Oh wait, Emma Thompson.
I mean, Emma Thompson?
Fricking read the paper right
now, Ned, what's going on?
Don't waste time.
He mails me the letter.
Emma Thompson writes me a
two-page handwritten letter,
saying how much she loves
the play, how she
wants to support it.
And she gives me her personal
email address, says contact me
if you want help.
Being the son of Pakistani
immigrants, I said sure, I
need some help.
Can you give me a
review blurb?
She gave me a great review
blurb, where she attaches her
name to the play and says
help me and Wajahat
staging this play.
Then she says ask me if you
want anything else.
So I said well, if you are
asking, why don't we-- why
don't you give me some funds
if you want to just donate.
So she sends me a check
for like about $1,500.
We get people like Yann Martell,
the author of "Life
of Pi." We get people
like Dave Eggers.
We end up getting all these
validators, diverse
invalidators, not just the
people, but also the ethnics.
Right?
We go to Sheik Google,
press Press Release.
Using all our contacts, we send
out the press release to
every mainstream outlet.
It's about August 2009.
The play's premiering 9/11/2009
in New York.
Two and a half weeks before
the play, we don't have a
single article on us, not
a single interview.
I had faith.
I said wait for it.
Within the last week, if you
build it, they will come.
And within the last week of the
play's premiere, we got
"The New York Times" feature.
We got MSNBC.
We got NBC.
We got Al Jazeera.
We got local, national,
international press.
People thought we would fail.
9/11 opening night.
Diverse multicultural crowd.
Sold out.
Word of mouth spread.
We ended up selling out week
three, week four, and week
five by the beginning
of the third week.
The Nuyorican Poets Cafe, who
was terrified that we will
sell no tickets, told us at
the end of our run that we
broke their 40-year box
office records.
And then-- yeah, thanks.
And then after--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
WAJAHAT ALI: I'll take
one "wow!" Fine.
Cause this is Google, right?
People are like (PAKISTANI
ACCENT) Pssht, five weeks.
Why wasn't it 50 weeks?
Loser.
Do you have Google
stock like I do?
No.
I'm better than you.
I know what Pakistanis think.
It's all good.
But I sold out.
And we broke the box
office records.
And finish, to finish,
I came back and I had
this dream, this vow--
I was 28--
to publish this play by
the time I turned 30.
Long story short, through this
journalism career, blogging
career, lawyer career that
just kind of fortuitously
bubbled up in the last two
years, I had a connection with
a Pulitzer-nominated author and
publisher of McSweeney's,
Dave Eggers.
And the email literally
went like this--
half-page email--
hey dude, I have a good idea.
McSweeney should publish
"Domestic Crusaders." Here's
10 reasons why.
If anyone has received emails
from me, they realize it seems
like it's sent by a six-year-old
child.
I don't use capitalization,
grammar, anything.
It's like pidgin English.
And I didn't even use
one, two, three--
I just did dashes.
I'm like you guys, I've
written a play.
The play's important.
It'll help you with the
multicultural audiences.
You like the play.
And so, why not?
He responds back to me in
typical professional fashion
dude, that's a great idea.
Let me give it to my board.
It's not up to me.
The board reads the play,
unanimously decides to publish
the play, and then a day after
turning 30, I held the first
copy of the "Domestic Crusaders"
that got published
in January 2001, is now being
taught at universities--
thank you.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
WAJAHAT ALI: And I can now
announce that I just signed
the contract right
before coming to
Google at Postal Annex.
I sent it off.
And "Domestic Crusaders," after
10 years, is actually
going to be in London in 2013.
And Emma Thompson, who's been so
nice, sent me an email last
night, said invite--
I look forward to it.
I'm going to come see
your production.
Come eat dinner at my house.
I will cook for you.
I really want to meet
you and your wife.
She really loved my marriage
story, which is on my blog.
Shameless, shameless
promotion.
But that's Emma Thompson.
And people like Dave Eggers, and
people like Carla Blank,
my director, people like Ishmael
Reed, a community who
believed in me that 10 years now
down the line, after I had
left the play, because
I published and
I'm like I'm done.
And the play got a
life of its own.
And then after I'd published it
and left, people have been
coming to me for the past two
years-- universities,
colleges, student groups,
and now England.
And it's been a long
fulfilling journey.
And I want to end
it on this note.
That uncle in 2003--
remember at Mehran Restaurant
who said (PAKISTANI ACCENT)
Beta, do something useful.
Go protest.
That uncle came up to me about
three years ago when we were
doing the play in New York.
That same uncle came up to me
and said listen, I've been in
this country for 40 years.
I've done everything right.
I'm a successful engineer.
I've paid taxes.
I've raised my kids right.
I've never done anything
wrong.
I turn on the TV, and they still
see me as either a cab
driver or a terrorist.
I wish I would've made
one of my sons into a
storyteller like you.
I realize there's so much
value in storytelling.
Keep doing what you're doing.
I support you.
And so that's something
fulfilling after 10 years.
And now I get to travel
the world, and I
don't ride my law degree.
I ride my pen.
And once in awhile, when I'm
lucky, someone makes chai for
me for a change.
So thank you for having
me, Google.
I'm done.
You guys have five minutes?
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
WAJAHAT ALI: You hear
that, YouTube?
You hear that?
All right.
AUDIENCE: This was
very engaging.
I was just wandering
through the halls
and heard you talking.
And you were engaging enough to
keep me occupied for your
entire story.
So thank you.
WAJAHAT ALI: Thank you sir.
Thank you for that.
The check is in the mail.
You performed admirably.
Thank you for that.
I appreciate it.
AUDIENCE: I actually wanted
to know about
your upcoming stuff.
I know you're working on a
screenplay and another play.
So if you can tell
us about that?
WAJAHAT ALI: Sure, the
upcoming stuff.
I'm working on my first movie
screenplay with a really cool
director by the name
of Josh Seftel.
He made this movie called "War,
Incorporated." I wish I
could tell you more.
It's a really cool story.
It's a fictional take on a real
life character who does
some amazing work.
So I'm learning how to
do a screenplay.
That's fun.
Me and Dave Eggers, for
two years, have been
working on a TV pilot.
HBO commissioned us on a pitch
we made about an American
Muslim cop in the Bay Area.
I really like the damn pilot.
I'm not just saying that
because we wrote it.
But I really think
it's damn good.
And it's a very, very
Bay Area pilot.
It's not just San Francisco.
It's East Bay and
San Francisco.
It's very real, very nuanced,
and layered.
We did the third draft.
I kicked over the third
draft to Dave.
He has to do the final edits.
Let's see what happens.
And somehow, this weird
circuitous professional path
has led to me being
a researcher on
Islamophobia in America.
And I've been working on some
upcoming research about the
rise of Islamophobia, but
specifically labeling and
singling out the Islamophobes.
And we label them in a big
report we did last year called
"Fear, Incorporated, The Roots
of the Islamophobia Network in
America," where we, for the
first time ever-- it was a
six-month investigative report,
where we traced all
the funding, traced the major
Islamophobic players and how
they have created these memes
that have entered in the
mainstream, such as President
Obama's a Muslim.
He isn't.
Or anti-Sharia threat,
and so forth.
So it's a really weird path.
But my family would really,
really like me
to still be an attorney.
And they're still trying to
figure out what I want to be
when I grow up.
But not my parents-- my
parents, nontypical,
nonstereotypical South
Asian parents--
I want to give a shout
out to my parents--
have always supported me since
I was like 9 or 10 years old.
So they keep telling me
to do what I'm doing.
But the larger family--
Pakistanis are a breeding
people.
We travel in a horde
of 60 or 70.
So they to this day still think
I failed in my life and
have not utilized
my law career.
And they think literally I just
sit there doing emails
all night till 4:00 AM.
But that's what I'm working
on right now.
AUDIENCE: Great talk.
WAJAHAT ALI: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to know
what you think of the
state of Muslim arts is in the
US, and what we could do to
encourage it.
WAJAHAT ALI: Ah, crap,
a thesis question.
The state of Muslim
arts right now.
Actually, it's a very
good question.
Real quick, I think it's not
surprising that after 9/11, we
saw a figurative creative
explosion of American Muslim
artistic endeavors.
And any time you look at any
ethnic minority, it usually
takes tremendous pain or love
that inspires this, right?
African Americans, Irish
Catholic, Jewish Americans.
Jewish Americans and African
Americans, not surprising,
suffered tremendously--
also, some of the creators
of the best
art in America, right?
And I think there's a permanent
fork road in the
timeline of 9/11.
We want to escape, but hopefully
we've reached the
post-post-9/11 climate.
And what we saw in the past 10
years is you see American
Muslims, like lawyers, doctors,
and engineers, who
left the trinity to do
stand-up comedy.
Now we see people like Willow
Wilson, my friend who's a
graphic novelist and writing
a book called Alif.
You see people emerging
in spoken word.
And what we're witnessing now--
and this is a test for
the American Muslims--
is when it comes to any ethnic
minority that doesn't have
mainstream publicity, they
want every single
representation to be an
avatar of perfection.
So they're like this is our
one shot at having a play.
This is our one shot
of having a Muslim.
We have to tell every
single story that
exists under the sun.
We have to show how
we're perfect.
And every time you expose warts,
there's tremendous push
back from the community,
which is what me
and others have witnessed.
Because they want the avatar
of perfection.
But what we know is that good
art reflects the warts.
It makes it interesting.
No one want to see
a perfect story.
It's boring.
And you want art to resonate.
So what we're seeing now is
a shift where I think many
American Muslim artists--
I know many of them.
They've had such tremendous
strain on them to always make
their art quote-unquote
"Islamic." Right?
There's always a tendency among
Muslims circles that the
art has to be Islamic.
What does that mean?
And there's like this religious
police that says you
didn't say Bismillah and
[URDU], didn't have
four suras in there.
This is not Islamic.
And they completely
dismiss it.
And what I want is to see
more artists who just
happen to be Muslim.
And that must mean also the way
our art gets better is to
change the mentality of American
Muslim communities
where you have to
make a big tent
approach to American Islam.
That means that if a person
identifies as Muslim, I'm not
interested in their piety
or their religiosity.
If they identify as a Muslim,
and they're willing to
contribute to the dialogue and
give something back, we have
to give them that space.
We have to acknowledge
that space.
And likewise we have
to acknowledge
artists in that space.
It might not always be
religious or pious or
conservative or liberal or
progressive, because the
progressives go into the
conservatives, all these labels.
My concern is number one make
the art good, because I think
good art attracts
good audiences.
Make it authentic.
And I think we as a community,
then, through our art, can
really push the boundaries and
make the tent of American
Islam bigger to encompass
all the stories,
not just one story.
And I hope I answered
that question.
But we're seeing it now.
Finally 10 years later, we're
finally seeing the shift where
you see an artist say I'm
writing a play, not about
Muslims or Islam, just
a play about people.
And I happen to be an
American Muslim.
And that's OK.
And if an American Muslim
says you know what?
I want to write a play which
has a political edge and a
religious edge, they should
have that space too.
I hope I got you there.
AUDIENCE: Obviously the--
you mentioned earlier
your ties to the--
the purported ties that people
make of you to these extremist
groups and all of this.
I'm curious if that started
as a result of "Domestic
Crusaders" or as a result of the
"Fear, Inc" publication.
WAJAHAT ALI: Right.
So I joked--
I was joking about my fictional
ties to extremist
groups-- quote unquote
"extremist groups." Look, it
started as a result of the
publication of "Fear,
Incorporated," where we
literally named all the names
of the key Islamophobes.
And we went into it very
strategically, knowing that's
how they'll retaliate.
Because one of their key goals
is to marginalize any American
Muslim voice that becomes
prominent, either in Google or
politics or the media, that
threatens their narrative,
which paints a civilizational
war between
the West versus Islam.
So any time an American Muslim
voice emerges in the
mainstream, they want to
marginalize that voice.
It's been happening for
the past 10 years.
Strategically, we knew that
was going to happen.
I looked at my track record,
and I'm like OK, let
them come after me.
And after the publication of
"Fear, Inc." which has been a
year, they have tried in very
desperate, amusing fashion to
call me like Wajahat
Ali, a man of hate.
And every time they print out
something, I just sit there
and read and laugh with my
friends, which I don't know if
it's normal.
Because my friends get really
upset on my behalf.
They're like Wajahat Ali,
look what they did.
All my friends-- regardless of
ethnicity, they're like I
can't believe they did that.
I just think it's very funny.
So I just read it and I laugh.
And they make these bizarre
obtuse links.
So they said I was a member of a
social group, Muslim Student
Association.
And they make these crazy links,
and then they say look,
I am a pawn of the radical
Muslim Brotherhood with the
agenda to infiltrate America and
replace the Constitution
with Sharia.
So this has been happening.
But because we've seen a shift
in the past one year or two
year, where the Islamophobes
have become so extreme.
And unfortunately, they've
infiltrated
the Republican Party.
The Republicans now even are
like, this is bad news for our
brand name and our party, which
is why you see people
like John McCain and even
Boehner go against Michele
Bachmann, who, if you don't
know, last year Michele
Bachmann came up with a memo
saying these names of these
American Muslims--
she named the names--
are part of the radical Muslim
Brotherhood agenda.
As a result of this witch hunt
and fear mongering, she was
blasted by John McCain, Boehner,
and even her former
campaign manager, Ed Rollins
who said it was shameful.
But she raised $1 million in
a month, based on that
fearmongering.
So they try to come after me,
but it's been very minor.
Mostly because I have
deliberately spoken to a
multicultural audience--
deliberately, intentionally--
and I've never said anything
really radical, I mean, if you
look at my stuff.
I stand by my political
opinions, even those that
might be unpopular.
I've tried to be very fair.
They've tried to attack me,
but it hasn't stuck.
And that's why I'm like OK,
if you want to come after
me come after me.
I'll come after you, which
is what we're doing.
And my hope is to expose
Islamophobes.
I want to be very transparent,
because they're a poison to
America, and specifically in
light of Anders Breivik the
Norwegian murderer who
killed 77 people.
He left behind a 1,500-page
manifesto, where he cites all
these American Islamophobia
that are mentioned in the
"Fear, Inc." report.
And experts have said that they
didn't cause him to do
this, but he emerges from
the same ideological
infrastructure.
So we want to expose
them because we
see them as a poison.
And when you expose people like
this, yes, you get hit.
But I've been very lucky, that
nothing's been able to stick.
So that's why I joke
about it so openly.
I'm like, yeah, Barack Obama,
my Muslim president.
We hang out and have dhal
and drink chai.
Sometimes we eat pork.
I'm just kidding.
I don't eat pork.
He's not Muslim.
If he is Muslim, he's the worst
Muslim of all time.
Chillax.
All right.
I hope I answered
your question.
I went a little too
detail into it.
Yeah, good?
Good.
AUDIENCE: Probably a two part
question, one is just building
on what you just talked about,
what's happening with the
recent movie and with
the [? stuff ?]
going on YouTube.
So the entire process, I also
want you to talk about the
mentality of the
people and your
psychoanalysis of the situation.
WAJAHAT ALI: My psychoanalysis
of the situation?
Wow.
I should have gotten
paid by Google.
Google needs to pay
me next time.
Go ahead.
You are a playwriter, so I
believe you would have that
[? deal ?].
And the second is do you think
about doing these plays
yourself, going out in Muslim
countries to actually build
awareness within those countries
about what they are
fighting for or what America is
for or what the values are.
WAJAHAT ALI: You cheated with
a two-part question.
But I'm going to answer.
Very quickly, I think, when it
comes to this unfortunate
movie that was released on
YouTube and subsequently has
spurned protests across Muslim
communities that have resulted
in deaths, I think extremism
begets extremism.
And I say that because the
makers of this documentary, if
you look at their ideological
ties, one of the film's
promoters deliberately said,
[? specifically ?] he said we
hoped this would happen, which
he's talking about the riots.
And he has ideological ties to
people like Pamela Geller and
Robert Spencer who were some
of the key Islamophobes we
mentioned in "Fear,
Incorporated," who are members
of the hate group Stop
Islamization of America.
So do they have a right
to create inflammatory
material like this?
I strongly believe they do.
Does that give a right
to anyone to
respond with violence?
No.
As a Muslim, I think those
Muslims who try to rationalize
and validate their violent
response by saying they are
defending the legacy of the
Prophet Muhammad, are in fact
betraying the legacy, spirit
and [? etiquette ?]
of the Prophet Muhammad.
And I'm not just saying that
to mince words, to be nice.
I sincerely mean that.
I had tremendous anger when I
saw people respond violently.
At the same time, what we should
know is that there's
1.5 billion Muslims.
And even in countries like
Libya, in Egypt, what we saw--
and I'm glad due to
globalization, we can finally
get this in the mainstream--
you saw protests against
the violent protesters.
You saw 30,000 Libyans come out
peacefully protesting the
violent protests that killed the
ambassador Chris Stevens.
And even you saw images of
Muslims worldwide saying this
does not represent Islam.
So when people say why
does the Muslim
world behave like this?
You say, it's not the
Muslim world.
Islam doesn't speak.
Muslims do.
And there's 1.4 billion
Muslims.
It's just some minority faction
in Pakistan, Egypt,
and so forth.
But a problem exists within
these countries, and it's very
deliberate when you see
the countries--
Tunisia, Egypt, Libya.
I mean, you see-- they
went through the
Arab Spring last year.
It's not surprising at all to
me that certain factions are
trying to play up on this,
which they do.
And I think what we're seeing
now, though, is a shift where
people understand that
it's not the majority
of Muslims in America.
The narrative still persists.
It's troubling.
And I think, again, extremism
begets extremism.
And this is why stories are so
important, because you need
more narratives out there.
Right?
You need more narratives than
the rage boy cover that came
out on "Newsweek" last week.
You guys see that cover?
Out of all the messengers, they
chose Ayin Hirsi Ali.
"Newsweek" has every right.
But it's like I always joked.
I said asking Ayin Hirsi Ali
to talk about Muslims is
asking like Mel Gibson to do
a convening about Jews.
Just because the Jews will be
like out of all the people
that you could choose, why would
you choose someone who's
made a creator out of being
inflammatory and
scholastically incorrect
with their analysis?
Right?
And so, again, you see
sensationalism
dominate the news.
But I think it does bring up
good points about art, the
role of art, the power
of art, cartoons.
People say art exists
in a vacuum.
It doesn't.
It informs the vacuum.
It reflects.
It reflects society.
And sometimes, unfortunately,
it explodes that vacuum.
And I think there's a
responsibility for Muslims
also to step up--
clergy, artists,
writers, and they have--
to denounce that act.
And I think there is a strategy
that needs to be to
respond intelligently, which
is something that
sometimes we don't do.
Pakistani uncles take a chai and
yell at Bill O'Reilly at
their home.
It's fun to yell at Bill
O'Reilly and Fox News, but
maybe there's some more
important strategies.
For the second question, very
quick, interest has come from
many Muslim countries--
"Muslim" countries.
Pakistan is really interested,
and they see value in it.
I think if we pull it
off in England--
I signed the contract.
Let's see what happens--
I think we go transatlantic
first, and I think it will
trickle down to other
countries.
But the beautiful thing about
being published is people are
reading it all around
the world.
And I know LUMS University--
anyone who went to LUMS
here in Lahore?
One person.
Congratulations.
LUMS University has
taught the play.
So it's good.
I hope I was able to answer your
two-part thesis question.
Thanks, guys.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
WAJAHAT ALI: Thank you.
Thank you, Suhair.
Thank you, Google.